[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci Gilles merci j'appelle maintenant
Delphine vespezer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec vous c'est bon c'est bon
et je ne fais jamais je vais être obligé
je vais être obligé d'appeler de leur
mot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah bah ça suffit elle est tellement
torride et érotique tu verras quand tu
quand tu seras avec
[Applaudissements]
tu as oublié de te cacher c'est
l'électricité c'est EDF cette meuf tu es
là mais c'est bon là
tu crois qu'il y a du soleil là
toi mon amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais demander un truc c'est passé
[Applaudissements]
on va faire quelque chose que je n'ai
jamais fait
je vais remettre le son depuis le début
on va mettre le son en entier je vais te
laisser une deuxième chance par contre
c'est sûr pas de porno gratuit je ne
sais pas faire mais c'est sensuel
c'est très important on se connaît à peu
près depuis 15 ans bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
exactement exactement
les
gars viens je vais interroger mon ami
Jean-Marie est-ce que tu es content de
cette première émission
pour moi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu euh
émotionnel émouvant la langue en fait
Jean-Marie était là en français en
anglais et dans le sexe language
Jean-Marie était là quand j'ai fait
l'émission avec Ardisson avec Julio et
tu as été adorable et moi je l'adore
non mais j'aime bien parce qu'on a passé
un super moment c'était en 2003
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la dernière c'est la dernière fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les Chéries Mathieu Mathieu je viens aux
affaires je viens je suis en train
d'envoyer spécial alors Mathieu
Delormeau
une révélation
je pense que je pourrais être en train
de devenir hétérosexuel
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
écoute embrasse-toi sur la bouche et
dire si je reçois un truc
non quelqu'un d'autre
[Rires]
avec moi mais ça m'a fait une chaleur
[Applaudissements]
on a fait des reportages ensemble et là
aussi passé
d'ailleurs je vais venir chanter encore
vendredi ou samedi
tu sais comment il est mort
[Rires]
est-ce que tu sais qu'elle est venue
chanter dans une boîte gay à Paris c'est
une icône gay de ouf là
franchement
jusqu'à présent mais là le stagiaire est
évident redonne une chance lâche-toi non
non
les gays sont powerful Like Me ou les
Big Boss l'action
s'il te plaît
les chéris les chéris Afida tu restes un
peu avec nous et vous alors
la première fois que tu dégages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec nous tu veux pas mettre une jupe
[Rires]
il a dansé mieux que tout le monde entre
deux normaux et lui franchement vous
êtes au top de votre game on va passer à
la maison